Gwen Stefani is 50 today per man Blake
Shelton tweeted happy birthday I love
you so much
it's actually stupid and possibly
illegal in the state of California
that's some big love all right we've got
our own gifts for Gwen and the formatted
et birthday throwback we hear Gwen is
over the moon about her mouth stone
birthday and feels confident in her age
a source tells et she's on vacation with
Blake right now but he wants to make her
feel special and is planning a big party
for her it's a costume party we know how
much Gwen loves costumes she's been a
trendsetter since we first met her back
in 1996 the pants didn't they don't fit
so I'm like oh you know
[Music]
the no doubt front woman has rocked more
looks than we can count from California
Beach punk to old Hollywood glam to
Harajuku girl she even made braces look
cool her fashion philosophy I always
breaks the rules and now is get everyone
always says bad things about me why she
wears so much but I like makeup and I
love dress up I never really thought
okay I want to be a fashion designer but
I thought I always made mouth so how
does the mom of three make fifty look
like 25
she says she stays out of the Sun and
claims I've always been into grocery
store makeup
[Music]
everybody knows what my love life is cuz
there's only couple of but when really
credits are natural glow to be lucky and
love with this guy anytime I can be
around Blake is I mean how amazing life
can be where you can go everybody has to
go through these challenges you know in
these dark times and and then those you
there's always a rainbow and that's what
my life feels like right now in so many
ways I'm just so grateful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]